Você sabia que existe uma molécula
natural capaz de limpar suas células
como se fosse uma faxina profunda,
eliminando o lixo celular, que te
envelhece, te adoece e destrói o seu
cérebro? E o melhor, você pode aumentar
os níveis dessa molécula, começando
hoje, sem receita médica, sem efeitos
colaterais graves. Estou falando da
espermidina. Em um estudo de 2024 acabou
de confirmar o que poucos médicos estão
dispostos a te contar. Essa substância
ativa um processo chamado autofagia, que
literalmente reverte o envelhecimento
celular e protege contra
neurodegeneração. Se você quer entender
como funciona esse processo de
rejuvenescimento celular e como aplicar
isso na sua vida real, fica comigo,
porque nos próximos minutos eu vou te
mostrar a ciência por trás dessa
revolução. Deixa eu explicar uma coisa
que a indústria médica não quer que você
saiba. suas células t um sistema de
limpeza interno, uma espécie de faxina
molecular que decide se você vai
envelhecer com saúde ou virar um
depósito ambulante de lixo celular. Esse
processo se chama autofagia,
literalmente significa comer a si mesmo
e é basicamente sua célula fazendo uma
limpeza geral, jogando fora proteínas
quebradas, mitocôndrias defeituosas,
todo o entúho que se acumula com o tempo
e que te deixa velho, doente e com
cérebro enferrujado. Agora vem a parte
que vai te deixar de queixo caído. A
espermidina, essa molécula que você
provavelmente nunca ouviu falar, é o
botão turbo da autofagia. Um estudo
publicado em 2024 na Nature Cell
Biology, uma das revistas científicas
mais prestigiadas do mundo, mostrou que
quando você faz jejum ou restrição
calórica, seus níveis de espermidina
disparam. E sabe o que acontece? Suas
células começam essa faxina profunda que
literalmente reverte o envelhecimento.
Os pesquisadores testaram isso em
leveduras, moscas, camundongos e até em
voluntários humanos. O resultado,
aumento da longevidade em todas as
espécies estudadas. Mas aqui está o
problema que ninguém te conta. Conforme
você envelhece, seus níveis de
espermidina despencam. É como se seu
corpo fosse perdendo a capacidade de se
limpar, acumulando cada vez mais nicho
celular, até que as suas células começam
a falhar, seus neurônios começam a
morrer e seu corpo literalmente começa a
entrar em colapso. E aí vem o médico
convencional te oferecer um remédio para
cada sintoma sem nunca tocar na raiz do
problema. a falência do sistema de
limpeza celular. Estudos recentes,
inclusive um de 2025 publicado no
Journal of Inherited Metabolic Disease,
mostraram que pacientes com distúrbios
neurológicos tratados com espermidina
tiveram melhora em aspectos relacionados
à motricidade e cognição. Sabe por quê?
Porque a espermina foi lá na raiz do
problema e religou o sistema de
autofagia que tava desligado. É como se
você tivesse uma casa suja há anos e
finalmente contratasse uma equipe de
limpeza profissional. Só que essa equipe
trabalha 24 horas por dia, 7 dias por
semana, dentro de cada uma das suas
trilhões de células. Deixe contar o que
acontece no seu cérebro quando a
autofagia para de funcionar direito.
Proteínas começam a se dobrar errado.
Isso mesmo. Proteínas mal formadas que
vão se acumulando nos seus neurônios
como entú abandonada. A ciência já
identificou isso no Alzheimer com a
proteína tal e a betamloide no Paxon com
a alfa sinucleína. Um estudo de 2024
publicado no Cell Death and Disease
mostrou que quando você reduz
parcialmente uma enzima chamada espermin
sintase, o que aumenta os níveis de
espermidina, a autofágia dispara, a
proteína tal é degradada e os neurônios
param de morrer. É literalmente reversão
de neurodegeneração acontecendo em tempo
real. Agora presta atenção nessa sacada
que vai mudar sua cabeça. Pesquisadoras
descobriram que quando você suplementa
com espermidina em camundongos de meia
idade com comprometimento cognitivo
leve, aquele esquecimento inicial que
todo mundo acha que é normal do
envelhecimento, três coisas
impressionantes acontecem. Primeiro, os
lisosomos, que são as usinas de
reciclagem celular, começam a degradar
as fibrilas de amiloide que estavam
entupindo o cérebro. Segundo, a função
dos receptores Glu A1, essenciais para
formar memórias novas, volta ao normal.
Terceiro, a capacidade de memória dos
bichos é completamente restaurada. Isso
foi publicado na Agencell em 2020 e
confirmado em múltiplos estudos desde
então. Mas tem um detalhe técnico aqui
que é importante você entender, a
espermidina não funciona sozinha. Ela
precisa de um processo chamado hipinação
da proteína EF5A. Parece complicado, mas
é simples. A espermidina modifica essa
proteína específica que então consegue
regular a produção de outras proteínas
essenciais para a função mitocondrial.
As mitocôndrias são as usinas de energia
das suas células e quando elas começam a
falhar, você literalmente perde a força
vital. Um trabalho de 2024 publicado na
Nature Cell Biology mostrou que a
espermidina protege as mitocôndrias do
cérebro envelhecido, mantendo-as
funcionando como se fosse de um
organismo jovem. E aqui vem o dado que
deveria estar estampado em todo o
custuório médico, mas que você nunca vai
ver. Estudos epidemiológicos com humanos
mostraram que pessoas que consomem mais
espermidina na dieta tem menor
mortalidade geral, especialmente por
doenças cardiovasculares e câncer. Isso
foi publicado no Autofage em 2019 pelo
grupo do Frank Made, um dos maiores
pesquisadores de longevidade do mundo.
Então eles acompanharam populações
inteiras e a correlação é cristalina,
mais permitida na dieta, mais anos de
vida saudável. Agora vamos falar de um
ensaio clínico recente que deveria estar
fazendo manchete, mas que está sendo
ignorado pela mídia. Pesquisadores deram
3,3 mg de espermina por dia para idosos
durante um ano inteiro. 42% dos
participantes tiveram melhora
significativa na performance cognitiva.
42%.
Isso é uma taxa de resposta
impressionante para qualquer
intervenção, especialmente uma
substância natural, sem efeitos
colaterais graves. O estudo foi
publicado em 2025 e mostrou que doses
mais altas tendem a funcionar melhor. Os
participantes que receberam doses
maiores tiveram melhorias ainda mais
pronunciadas. Mas aqui está a pegadinha
que a indústria farmacêutica odeia. Você
não precisa de um remédio patenteado
caríssimo para aumentar os seus níveis
de permidina. Você pode fazer isso
através da alimentação e da
suplementação. Alimentos ricos em
espermidina incluem germen de trigo,
infelizmente, né, temos que considerar o
glút aí, queijos envelhecidos,
cogumelos, legumes, grãos integrais e
produtos de soja fermentados. E tem
mais, você pode aumentar a produção de
dentro, endógena dispermidina,
consumindo probióticos específicos,
especialmente o bife do bactérium
láctes, encontrado em iogurtes de
qualidade. Isso foi demonstrado em
adultos saudáveis que viram os seus
níveis intestinais de espermidina
subirem significativamente. Agora, deixa
eu te dar a perspectiva funcional que
nenhum médico convencional vai te dar. A
espermidina trabalha em múltiplas
frentes simultaneamente. Não é só
autofagia. Ela reduz estresse oxidativo,
protege as mitocôndrias, diminui
inflamação sistêmica, melhora a função
vascular, promove angiogênese cerebral,
facilita a transmissão sináptica,
estimula a migração neuronal e induz
neuritogênese, que é basicamente o
crescimento de novos contatos entre
neurônios. É uma intervenção de espectro
completo que ataca todos os pilares do
envelhecimento de uma vez só. E tem um
aspecto que poucos discutem, mas que é
crucial. A espermidina mimetiza os
efeitos da restrição calórica e do jejum
intermitente. Lembra que eu falei que os
níveis de permidina sobem quando você
faz jejum? Pois é, você pode
potencializar os efeitos combinando o
jejum intermitente com suplementação
espermidina. é como apertar o acelerador
e o turbo ao mesmo tempo. Estudos em
camundongos mostraram que essa
combinação oferece proteção
cardiovascular superior, melhora da
artrite, extensão robusta tanto da
longevidade quanto do período de vida
saudável. Eu vou te dar um exemplo
prático de como isso funciona na
neuroproteção. Pesquisadores de 2024
descobriram que a espermidina previne
alterações sinápticas relacionadas à
idade na região do hipocampo, aquela
região cerebral essencial para formar
memórias. Especificamente, ela protege a
sinapse entre as fibras musgosas e os
neurônios C3, que são cruciais pro
processo de consolidação de memórias de
longo prazo. Sem essa sinapses
funcionando direito, você literalmente
perde a capacidade de criar memórias
duradouras. A espermidina também mantém
essas conexões jovens e funcionais.
Agora, uma informação que vai fazer
sentido para quem entende biologia
celular. A espermidina regula a
acetilação de proteínas. Ela funciona
como inibidor de estona de acetilases,
que são as famosas HDCs.
São enzimas que controlam quais genes
são expressos. É o mesmo mecanismo
respveratrol, só que a espermina
funciona por vias ligeiramente
diferentes e converge com resveratrol
que chamamos de acetilproteoma.
Isso significa que ela está literalmente
modificando a expressão genética em
direção a um perfil mais jovem e
saudável. E aqui está uma descoberta
fascinante publicada em 2024. Quando
você reduz parcialmente, não totalmente,
mas parcialmente a enzima espermine
sintase, você cria um estado metabólico
onde a espermidina se acumula levemente
e a autofagia dispara. Esse foi o achado
do estudo com moscas da fruta modelando
a doença de Alzheimer. A redução parcial
da enzima levou a degradação aumentada
da proteína tal, redução da
neurodegeneração e proteção contra a
morte celular. O mais interessante, a
análise proteica de cérebros de
pacientes com Alzheimer mostrou elevação
modesta, mas significativa dos níveis de
SMS. Não é o negócio do celular, é
enzima que converte espermidina em
espermina. Isso sugere que o cérebro
Alzheimer está tentando compensar algo,
mas não consegue. Vamos falar então de
números concretos, porque números não
mentem. Em estudos com camundongos, a
suplementação comermidina aumentou a
expectativa de vida em até 25%. Em
moscas da fruta, o aumento foi ainda
maior. Em humanos, obviamente, não temos
estudos de longividade completos, porque
levariam décadas, mas os marcadores
intermediários são inequívocos. Melhora
de biomarcadores cardiovasculares,
redução de marcadores inflamatórios,
melhora da função cognitiva, aumento da
resposta imune, inclusive melhor
resposta a vacinas em idosos. Isso foi
demonstrado em estudo de 2020, onde a
autofagia em células T de doadores
idosos era mantida pela espermidina e
isso correlacionava diretamente com
melhor resposta vacinal. E agora vem a
parte que separa a abordagem funcional
da medicina convencional. A medicina
convencional vai te dar memantina para
Alzheimer, levodopa para Paxon,
estatinas pro coração, tratando cada
órgão como se fosse uma peça isolada de
máquina. A visão funcional entende que
existe um denominador comum, a falência
de autofagia, o acúmulo de dano celular,
a disfunção mitocondrial. Trata a raiz
do problema com algo que seu corpo
reconhece e sabe usar. uma molécula
natural que seus próprios níveis
produzem massa que vai caindo com a
idade. Não é suprimir sintomas, é
restaurar a função. Um ponto crucial que
precisa ser entendido, a espermidina não
é uma bala mágica isolada, ela funciona
melhor dentro de um contexto mais amplo
de otimização metabólica. Isso significa
sono adequado, exercício regular, manejo
de estress, alimentação rica em
polifenois e fibras, jejum intermitente
ocasional, exposição solar para vitamina
D, controle glicêmico do açúcar, né,
otimização hormonal, se for necessário.
A espermidina potencializa todos esses
fatores e é potencializada por eles. É
uma sinfonia e não uma nota isolada.
Estudos mostram que a espermidina é
particularmente efetiva quando combinada
com outras estratégias que promovem
autofagia. O exercício físico, por
exemplo, aumenta a tofagia muscular e
cerebral. Agora vamos endereçar a
questão da segurança, porque eu sei que
você está se perguntando, será que é
seguro? A espermidina é uma poliamina
que está presente em todas as células
vivas do planeta. Você produz
espermidina naturalmente. Você consome
espermidina em praticamente todos os
alimentos que come, só que em
quantidades variáveis. Estudos
suplementação em humanos não relataram
efeitos adversos significativos. A
literatura científica acumulada em
múltiplas espécies ao longo de mais de
15 anos mostra perfil de segurança
excelente. Claro que sempre existe a
ressalva de que suplementação em doses
suprafisiológicas deve ser monitorada,
mas estamos falando de doses que
simplesmente restauram os níveis que
você tinha quando era mais jovem. Uma
questão técnica importante que nem toda
espermina é igual. A forma sintética
idêntica natural em termos de estrutura
química, mas a fonte importa sim em
termos de pureza e biodisponibilidade.
Extratos de germen de trigo são uma
fonte natural rica. Suplementos
purificados oferecem dosagem mais
precisa. A dose estudada em ensaios
clínicos humanos varia entre 1,2 a 3,3
mg por dia, mas alguns pesquisadores
sugerem que doses maiores podem ser mais
efetivas chegando até 5 10 mg de ários.
O timing também parece importar.
Consumir com comida pode melhorar a
absorção, mas consumir em jejum pode
maximizar os efeitos autofágicos.
Deixa te contar sobre um mecanismo
específico que explica porque que a
espermidina é tão poderosa pro cérebro.
Ela ativa uma via chamada pink um
parking, que é responsável pela
mitofagia, autofagia específica de
mitocôndrias defeituosas. Mitocôndrias
quebradas produzem radicais livres que
danificam DNA, proteínas e lipídios.
Elas também sinalizam processos
inflamatórios. A espermidina identifica
essas mitocôndrias problemáticas e as
marca para a destruição, substituindo-as
por mitocôndrias novas e saudáveis
através da biogênese mitocondrial. É
renovação celular real acontecendo. E
tem mais uma camada de sofisticação
aqui. A espermidina também modula a
inflamação através de múltiplos
mecanismos. Estudos em células
microgliais. As células imunes do
cérebro mostraram que a espermidina
reduz a produção de citocinas
pró-inflamatórios, como é o caso da TNF
alfa, tererleucina 1 beta, terleucina 6,
quando essas células são estimuladas com
lipo polissacarídeo. Isso significa
proteção contra a neuroinflamação, que
sabemos ser um dos motores principais de
doenças, como é o caso Alzheimer,
Parkson, esclerose múltipla e até
depressão. Então, vamos conectar todos
os pontos porque essa é a visão
integrativa de verdade. O envelhecimento
não é um processo inevitável de
deterioração aleatória. É um programa
biologicamente regulado que pode ser
modulado. A espermidina atua em
múltiplos alvos simultaneamente. Promove
autofagia, limpa o lixo celular, protege
e renova mitocôndrias fornecendo energia
sustentável, reduz inflamação sistêmica
prevenindo o dano tecidual, melhora a
função cardiovascular metando o óxido
nítrico. Otimiza a função sináptica
mantendo plasticidade cerebral. regula a
expressão genética em direção a perfis
mais jovens. É intervenção de sistemas e
não tratamento de sintomas. Aqui está o
que você precisa entender sobre a
diferença entre medicina convencional e
abordagem funcional quando falamos de
neuroproteção. A medicina convencional
espera você desenvolver Alzheimer
clínico: memória ruim, confusão mental,
incapacidade para então te dar drogas
que mal arranham a superfície do
problema. A abordagem funcional olha
para os 20, 30 anos antes dos sintomas
aparecerem e pergunta como mantemos a
tofagia funcionando, como prevenimos
acúmulo de proteínas tóxicas, como
mantemos mitocôndrias saudáveis, como
evitamos neuroinflamação crônica. A
espermidina é uma das ferramentas mais
poderosas nesse arsenal preventivo. Um
último ponto que é absolutamente
crítico, a janela de intervenção.
Estudos mostram que quanto mais cedo
você começa a suplementação com
espermidina, maiores os benefícios a
longo prazo. Isso não significa que
começar mais tarde seja inútil. Os
estudos em dosos com comprometimento
cognitivo já estabelecido mostram
benefício, claro, mas a estratégia ideal
é preventiva. Se você tem 40, 50, 60
anos e quer chegar aos 80, 90, 100 com
cérebro funcionando, esse é o momento de
agir. Não quando você já não consegue
lembrar o nome dos seus netos. A
espermidina representa uma mudança de
paradigma em como pensamos sobre
envelhecimento e neurodegeneração.
Não é só sobre mascarar sintomas ou
aceitar declínio como inevitável. é
sobre ativar mecanismo de renovação
celular que o seu corpo já possui mass
que foram se desligando com o tempo. É
medicina regenerativa no livro mais
fundamental, celular e molecular. E a
ciência não poderia ser mais clara,
funciona em deveduras, em vermes, em
moscas, em camundongos. E os dados
clínicos e humanos estão começando a
confirmar o que os modelos animais já
previram. Isso é biologia conservada ao
longo da evolução. O que significa que
quando uma intervenção funciona em
múltiplas espécies, a probabilidade de
funcionar robustamente humanos é
altíssima. Então, quando você ouviu o I
falar que envelhecimento é inevitável,
que perder a memória normal, que não tem
nada a fazer além de aceitar o declínio,
você vai saber que isso é mentira. Você
tem sim ferramentas. Apermidina é uma
delas e provavelmente é uma das mais
poderosas que a ciência identificou até
agora. O conhecimento está aí, os
estudos estão publicados nas melhores
revistas científicas do mundo, a
segurança está estabelecida, os
mecanismos são compreendidos. A única
pergunta que resta é: você vai usar essa
informação a seu benefício ou vai
continuar na inércia que leva ao
declínio inevitável?
[Música]
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade conveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, assessorar
dosagens, omitir protocolos
controversos. Na comunidade fechada não
existe esse filtro. Compartilho os
exatos protocolos que eu uso na minha
clínica. Casos de reversão que parecem
possíveis. Combinações of label que
funcionam. Fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Temos lives
semanais respondendo perguntas, PDF
exclusivo com 47 protocolos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para as massas,
clique em seja membro. E não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.
Agora, se você quer ir ainda mais fundo,
existe o nível dois. A cada duas semanas
nós fazemos live de imersão total, 2
horas de duração, desse artigos
científicos, linha por linha, debatendo
controvérsias que ninguém ousa tocar,
revelando os bastidores das pesquisas
que a indústria não quer que você
entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna a parte
visível dessa comunidade de elite que
está reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará ao meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade, tendo seu
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. Não é
só sobre aprender, é sobre pertencer ao
ciclo interno de quem está mudando o
jogo. Poucos têm a coragem. Você tem
agradecimentos especiais aos nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada no YouTube, José
Fortunato Marinho, Fernando Machado, Sou
Juciuli, Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril,
Estela Mares, Eloterapias Integrativas,
Saúde e Antes da Doença. E eu agradeço o
coração pelo apoio prestado.